First up-- hacking Hillary.
Hacking Hillary.
Cruella De Vil cosplayer
Hillary Clinton,
the candidate America's...
the candidate America's
settling on--
'cause let's face it,
we're not getting any younger--
has maintained a steady lead
at the polls
with her strategy
of not talking to the press
and waiting for Trump to just
finally say the "N" word. Uh...
-(laughter)
-But...
There, I said it.
I said it, okay?
But the far right
has been attacking her
over so-called health concerns,
and this coughing fit
at a campaign stop in Cleveland
is only going to fan
those conspiracy theory flames.
Take a look.
(Clinton coughing)
Every time I think about Trump,
I get allergic.
(laughter)
Uh, did anyone expect her
to go, "It's me, Bernie Sanders.
It's me!"
Oh!
So, comedians, you're comedians.
What's your Hillary quip
to explain her coughing fit?
Ron Funches.
Oh, I'm sorry, y'all,
I was smoking on that strong...
HARDWICK:
All right.
And unlike Bill, I did inhale.
HARDWICK:
All right.
(cheers and applause)
(bell dings)
HARDWICK: I said Hillary's,
not yours, Ron, not your answer.
Tiffany.
Well, if you listened
really closely you can hear
what she's really saying.
And she's like,
(coughs)
"I'm all you got."
(laughter)
HARDWICK: Points.
Kyle Kinane.
I think she's trying to say,
"(bleep) off, Bernie would
have had three strokes
and driven through
a farmers market by now."
(laughter)
HARDWICK:
Points, points for Kyle.
Send us your high school
in five words
and tag those @midnight
to keep the game going.
We'll be right back
with more @midnight.
HARDWICK: Our Tweet of the Day
from our last #HashtagWar
was sent to us by at guil,
oh, uh, stevenson.
Well done!